quelle était l'année qui détenait
jusqu'à présent le record de chaleur
en 2020 c'était elle avait une anomalie
positive de 1,11 degrés
et donc là on est une anomalie quand
même de 1,55 degrés ce qui était énorme
on a une moyenne sur la France de 14,5
tout au long de l'année ce morceau mal a
été l'attraction de la ville de
schaerbeuro dans le nord de l'Angleterre
tout le week-end du Nouvel An qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait il ronflait il a l'air
très heureux et les relaxe l'animal
baptisé tort se réagit de 3 à 5 ans et
serait en bonne santé pour préserver sa
tranquillité la municipalité a installé
un périmètre de sécurité pour tenir la
foule à distance elle a aussi annulé le
feu d'artifice du Nouvel An pour ne pas
l'effrayer à la jonction entre 2022 et
2023 on a pris un coup de chaud sur
l'Europe veut dire qu'en France on a
battu des sur 150 stations ce qui est
quand même énorme et toute l'Europe a
été comme ça et il y a au moins cinq
pays qu'on a pu compter jusqu'à l'heure
actuelle qui ont battu leur record pour
un mois de janvier alors vous voyez tous
les pays qui sont là j'insiste sur la
Pologne je vous donne une indication
Varsovie on avait 18 degrés normalement
c'est 1 degré cette période de l'année
et oui je suis rayonné
thorseman qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
où il y a un événement non quelque chose
évidemment on va bien on va bien on va
bien
il faut il faut leur expliquer ce que
c'est pas à moi de le faire
dans le conseil
attention
deux en couple a déjà trompé sa femme au
moins une fois donc on fait le tour du
plateau je vais te dire ils sont obligés
bah pardon moi je confesse toi toi toi
à la maison
ça compte pas à la maison non mais zéro
qui a trompé sa femme à la maison moi ça
m'est arrivé
et moi je ne recule devant rien oui je
peux avant midi vous montrer une
branlette à la télé qu'est-ce qu'on a à
faire voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est un classement qui fait beaucoup
parler les 200 meilleurs chanteurs et
chanteuses de l'histoire sélectionné par
le magazine Rolling Stones peu de
critiques sur la numéro 1 Aretha
Franklin
en revanche une artiste brille par son
absence Céline Dion
et ça c'est fan nombreux sans plaignent
en masse d'autant que d'autres
chanteuses étonnent par leur présence
les noms de Billie eilish Ariana grande
ou encore alia revienne souvent
et puis aux États-Unis plus anecdotique
mais tout de même c'est une autre
légende qui a été ovationnée lors d'un
match de basket c'est notre roi du foot
à nous Kylian Mbappé regardez le ici à
l'image le public l'a applaudit
longuement pendant plusieurs minutes
lors d'un match de NBA à New York ce qui
confirme évidemment qu'il est sacrément
populaire à l'étranger tout à l'heure tu
as parlé d'honnêteté tu te souviens tu
disais à Marco on peut réussir en étant
honnête est-ce que quand tu vends 8 fois
le même documentaire à C8 de Disney en
changeant facturer
[Applaudissements]
merci déclare notamment ceux-ci je suis
surpris que les gens soient si atteints
par la guerre en Ukraine est-ce que ça
veut dire que quand c'est en Afrique
vous êtes moins atteint alors dit comme
ça et sortez du contexte le propos peut
laisser penser comme arsy relativise les
horreurs de la guerre en Ukraine et
reproche sur français d'y être trop
sensible en réalité si on lit
l'entretien dans son intégralité ce
n'est pas ce qu'il dit on résume tu
accordais une interview parisien et
plusieurs phrases sur l'Ukraine ont été
sorties de leur contexte Nathalie
Loiseau BFM et la fachosphère se sont
emballés comment tu as vécu ça comme
d'habitude
journaliste du Parisien qui a recueilli
cet entretien ne comprend pas la
polémique il écrit que tout cela a été
dit sans aucune virulence et sur un ton
convaincu mais apaisé et ses propos ils
ont tout donné une proquet de nombreuses
réactions politiques notamment
rassemblement rassemblement national ou
bien de la part de l'ancienne ministre
Nathalie Loiseau qui rappelle que 59
soldats français sont morts récemment en
soldats ce qui fine signifie que non les
Français ne sont pas indifférents aux
guerres en Afrique finalement c'est pas
vraiment ce que je dis le problème je le
vois bien c'est ce que je suis et ce que
je suis en train de devenir à chaque
fois que que je sors de là je parle de
ce film tirailleurs qui parle bien de la
France qui parle bien de la guerre et
c'est assez clair en fait le propos
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui sont tous différents avec un angle
différent mais même sa langue tu étais
même pas journaliste ta carte de prêtre
tu t'es foutu dans le
vexé là une intégrité
mais c'est justement cette popularité
qui fait que ses prises de position font
toujours du bruit il a fait savoir par
exemple au fil des ans qu'il voteraient
contre Marine Le Pen il a traité Éric
Zemmour de clown il a dénoncé les
violences policières et il se trouve à
chaque fois des gens pour lui contester
le droit d'avoir ses opinions et sans
doute pas seulement parce qu'il vit à
Los Angeles ce qui est clair c'est pas
ce que je dis qu'on attaque
c'est moi et c'est pas un problème trop
tard les gars
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]